hi I'm Eric Voss and this is a review of
Blade Runner 2049 the long-awaited
sequel to the 1982 sci-fi classic Blade
Runner now starring Ryan Gosling and
with Harrison Ford reprising his role as
Deckard this film is a cinematic
masterpiece I left the theater totally
mesmerized but like the original Blade
Runner it's also not a film that exactly
makes it easy for everyone in the
audience to keep up with it for me
that's part of its genius and I'll get
to white later but first just a heads up
I'm gonna avoid any major plot spoilers
in this review that said in case you
want to avoid any discussion of the
film's characters it means I do get into
that stuff so a possible spoiler warning
okay so first we should remind ourselves
that it's surprising that the sequel
even exists the original Blade Runner
wasn't much of a blockbuster a cult hit
with a huge thematic and visual
influence on the sci-fi genre sure but
nothing like Ridley Scott's previous
film alien which launched a massive
franchise and as I rewatched the old
film this week in preparation for 2049 I
was struck by how my memory of Blade
Runner was at odds with the film it
actually was like when I think a Blade
Runner I think before it's time sci-fi
crime mystery with mind-blowing visuals
and profound observations on human
nature and sure Blade Runner is still
technically all those things but when
you're watching it it feels more
understated than that the scale feels
more intimate and the profound themes I
remembered were actually hidden under
long gaps of silence between lines so I
found it ironic that Blade Runner uses
false memories as advice within the
movie the character Rachel was a new
model of replicant who had memories of a
real human girl implanted in her mind so
that she would believe she was a human
and her responses would seem more
human-like so according to Blade Runner
our memories are what make us human
they're the most authentic thing about
us they make up our very soul if there
is such a thing
god I sound like a replicant now in 2049
director Denny Villeneuve uses this
conflict between our memory of the past
and the objective truth of the past to
structure the whole film the characters
confront memories that they aren't
entirely certain or real but also the
film on a meta level confronts the
memory of its predecessor challenging
you to really think about what about
Blade Runner made it Blade Runner let's
talk about how this concept plays into
the different elements of the
starting with the characters the
protagonist is Kay played by Ryan
Gosling a Blade Runner who hunts down
old models of replicants hiding among us
kay investigates a mystery that
unexpectedly triggers a personal memory
of his own a memory that until now he
assumed was just some BS distortion of a
childhood event that probably didn't
happen the fact that this memory could
be real for us triggers our memory of
the first movie but here it's flipped in
that version a character confronts his
memories and learns that they might have
been false here the main character
learns that his memories might have been
truer than he initially thought and in
both cases calling their memories into
question enlists the viewer into a
fascinating investigation what makes
this guy tick what makes them human we
searched Gosling's well-known pokerface
foretells and scour every frame of this
movie for clues it's almost like the
viewers are scanning the movie under our
own void comp replicant test now I don't
want to say too much about Harrison
Ford's character Deckard in this movie
but this guy is also at odds with his
memories throughout the movie characters
referred to a past event called the
blackout that wiped out all digital
records actually the prequel anime
blackout 2022 covers this event and you
should definitely watch it and in this
movie that blackout has left Deckard
essentially without an objective past he
has his memories but as we know those
memories authenticity is questionable at
best in many ways the key to this movie
is confronting Deckard's memories to
unlock huge revelations about humanity
now I could go into how this memory
concept inspired all of the characters
of this movie but it's really more fun
when you see it yourself so instead I'm
gonna move on to the setting of the film
so a Blade Runner 2049 obviously takes
place in 20 49 30 years after the events
of the first Blade Runner and what's
most interesting to me about this is for
a film that takes place even further
into the future how much of the setting
actually looks backward whereas the
first blade runner took entirely within
the city limits of Los Angeles this
sequel opens on a rural California farm
granted this is a 2049 farm and the
barren small covered landscape isn't
exactly pastoral but this opening sets
up a future that's obsessed with the
memory of the past later in the film a
major sequence takes place in an old
Vegas casino nostalgic images of Elvis
Presley and Frank Sinatra
liquor in and out as their music echoes
through the rooms people are trying to
immerse themselves in nostalgia as if it
will trigger the memory of something
long-forgotten
so did it work the challenge with the
Blade Runner sequel has always been how
could anyone make a sequel that lives up
to Ridley Scott's moody impressionistic
Syfy Mar that traded in high-speed
action for patient philosophical
dialogue with its famously ambiguous
alternate endings across multiple recut
whereas most directors would back away
from that risk and instead make a
simpler dumb-down sequel that just takes
place in that same cool world
I think Denis Villeneuve overcame this
challenge by extending and deepening the
themes of the first film resulting in a
sequel that is a true cinematic triumph
20:49 embraces our collective memory of
blade runner's cultural impact and
confronts that memory by delivering a
film that is even more patient even more
symbolic even more introspective and
even more visually bleak and to be
honest not every viewer can get on board
with that kind of film not everyone
loved the first Blade Runner when it
came out either but think of these films
like poetry they force you to think
about them to experience them again and
pull meaning from them and that need for
you to aggressively interpret it leaves
you with this lasting personal
connection to the film as you walk out
of the theater that human connection
made the first Blade Runner
unforgettable and I predict the memory
of Blade Runner 2049 will remain
stirring in our minds as well now if you
love Blade Runner and thinking deeply
about what these films mean and by
impressing your friends with how smart
you are another channel besides this one
that I can't recommend enough is
wisecrack they make super insightful
entertaining funny videos about all the
same stuff that we love specifically
their quick-take series is awesome
Jared's video on the philosophy and
symbolism of Blade Runner and how it
connects to the Blade Runner anime
blackout 2022 that I mentioned earlier
this was exactly the kind of thoughtful
video essay we aim to do here and you
should absolutely give it a watch before
seeing 2049 so check out Weitz cracks
page by clicking below in the link in
the description and subscribe to ice
crack and hey why not subscribe to us
too we actually have more Blade Runner
2049 videos planned for the future
digging more into the film's meaning and
visual and song choices like and share
this video and if you have any more
thoughts about Blade Runner you can
tweet me at EA boss or problem
rock stars on twitter at new rock stars
for updates on our videos alright thanks
for watching bye